yeah
oh buying a job
oh my god
a welcome to three-day oh my god
freedom you know which is so rather
random
oh three is giving me life
are you still alive yeah yeah that's
the only thing really okay so we
have to continue doing the show live
or die this is three am i'm
paul two xl i'm scott i'm laurie
and before the show before we start
recording laura and i gave each other
a foot high five and boy was
it wild scott went
absolutely crazy i said i said that
was not a high five because deep
shit because it's gym level but then
i realised it's high for a foot
high foot but they point out i'd
tie for so for michael flatley the
lower that's right it's low for his
feet yeah he'd be like what did
they do it all the way down
there here we are recreating or pre-show
bam because he was so good we
always good dog yeah
yes so ah alright well that's our
episode and goodbye so okay huh guys
ah wordle today this is a couple
of weeks ago for fitness oilers so
no spoilers for you but world today
somehow i spoiled it for paul yeah
because lauren and i both both ah
did it and
the word happened to be a three-team
word yes by the word of a
word closely associated with the three-time podcasts
weren't even more closely associated with the
three-time podcast phone number and that's right
the word today was input haha and
i and i invisible ink texted but
and everyone knows these are spoilers so
if you yes if if you haven't
played your wordle yet not to not
to click on bingeing world you started
from the beginning two days ago i
had this you know because i know
what your star-lord is and i saw
i thought i saw yeah then those
two letters are in the word and
yeah i know this was the same
star where i've used the same star
wars and now i now i want
to be laugh
last all the time and the first
shall be last we start to ah
go fuck yourself to me but in
kind terms it's a jew a jew
a jew a jew um but yeah
anyway so i should be last now
because i'm giving right hand says or
or i'll do invisible ink but here's
the thing because we will
invisible ink on the thread because then
it doesn't spoil it for people who
haven't played yet but i you know
you get the notifications as the i
don't have those turned on my everything
sure don't hop up on a text
at the top i haven't turned on
because they turn me on whoa you
got turned on like you smell like
a round massive yeah from notification god
it's small
really i'm sorry yes it's cheating
i get a teeny boner
you have a huge one lasted view
and i get around yeah exactly and
then wanting to rouse outta here but
it's so raw it compresses yeah really
cool
you could cut glass with it anyway
i don't think you shouldn't do it
did and will have had done you
small boner
what kind of glassy trying to cut
stained for the church yeah come on
lord i mean you know very devout
yeah that's cool please don't tell them
gotcha but mind
yeah but you didn't want anybody one
of those tools right well my day
charge an arm and a leg for
those things and i have a record
direction
um what the fuck but anyway so
the fish came in without the invisible
i think it's fucked up is i
think there is an agreement with iphone
that if you send something which is
invisible to me assure us but it's
in this the terms of service that
if you send something with invisible ink
you ye shall receive it with invisible
ink but you know it's tough because
because typically invisible ink i feel is
only used for bits and games you
know people aren't typically putting like top
secret info in the mage you don't
think that the c i a is
using invisible subjects if they're not stupid
they might be but my point is
you know they wouldn't put fireworks at
the top of your screen if a
firework text came in so i guess
it
makes sense that they're not gonna put
the word and it might even upscale
works when the firework texts come oh
yeah and we sent wu like i
was like oh my god who's ever
say you who's texting no i'm i'm
saying who's texting about fire about fire
yeah how when you say happy birthday
to somehow fireworks ten fatty or blue
confetti and balloons and all that i
thought you meant when someone's like texting
hey look at the fireworks and fireworks
automatic yeah so okay happy birthday gets
balloons congratulations gets confetti or there are
other ones that are triggered automatically by
phase probably have the most like secret
easter eggs like vienna and
out like happy easter eggs yeah oh
my god we gotta start saying everything
ever wonder if you sappy fourth of
july fireworks go let's talk illustrate okay
alright let's i'm i'm gonna text i
can't wait for this text to come
through happy fourth of july oh you
know what i'm gonna leave my lockscreen
on to see if it just says
like hell before the july and then
sent with fireworks or some shit okay
here we go ready yeah
i'm ready i've sent it let me
know when it gets there i got
it and it just says happy july
four i want to put it in
my county huh okay i'm gonna say
happy independence day yeah yes welcome to
earth when i try i'm gonna try
spelling out happy fourth of july okay
i've sent it happy for nothing name
on happy fourth of july
i no man what do you do
and i i'll try another one let's
try happy easter okay give me a
happy easter none nothing okay nothing okay
this probably work okay this is gonna
work
gum you send it with fireworks so
you said do well my guess is
he's come merry christmas nothing nothing what
the hell maybe it has to be
on the actual day but about i'm
sorry
buddy
nope god i guess we'll sub taxation
this should be yeah we've done all
we can do haha info anyway yeah
so you you saw the answer on
your fourth guess so it's in a
way i helped you out no yeah
that's what i'm saying is that you
i inadvertently got a hint yeah it
did not yeah like have you ever
seen what the answer is but you
still want to try to like play
yeah like i'm like i've done that
a couple of times where i knew
what the word was going to be
but i didn't wanna just put it
in and get what the first time
i'm like well when i have my
score be realistic yeah what would i
probably put where would i have gone
from there how would i have gotten
that sounds like wichita
but now janey i think all things
a waste of time to be on
yeah cheney tomkins janie haddad tompkins yes
janie had that dump dans janie had
a thompson she even though she hadn't
played yet she wanted to cheat so
she had an invisible inked it and
then this is how i find out
she does not listen to the show
she says what is this
mean ah la you she didn't didn't
find out by guessing yeah and she
said she replied that she's a fan
of threesome in real life yeah yeah
now my thing just mickelson a three-time
he listens if i play it to
edit it back you know i mean
yeah fair play it back at it
because you're editing every episode i was
so tightly
right i haven't done it for the
last few i'm proudly shooter but i
just you know these episodes typically run
about two hours thirty minutes and lauren
ayesha me down and i always make
sure that all the shutdown anywhere coming
up science yeah and you leave in
some stuff that's not funny just to
make it keep it real oh yeah
yeah like we're not a huge instantly
funny yeah
but you've come out super funny stuff
well because it didn't make sense exactly
was too personal
it was sol areas but way cheaper
you're talking about death of loved ones
it was so funny but you're so
like dad did but i found out
about but it was hilarious it was
hilarious good stuff paul did you have
a nice weekend we already talked we
learned i talked to off mike about
our weekends our respective you didn't wait
for me for weekend church now but
we can do it now loosely
um oh hold on loosely hold on
loosely hang on loosely hold on hang
on sloop hang out i'll lose law
now hold on hold on lucy loosely
hold hang on snoopy snoopy come home
so do you know is it say
hello i'm now i don't know i
think it
might be guy because i'm sure i
both of these oh loosely yeah yeah
but not oh lose the nominee loosely
lose hat
alright here we're gonna play hold on
loosely but hold on thirty eight special
unit was answer that question but i
guess we're gonna listen to the song
oh hold on loosely
yes and this is one of our
favorite jams coming at you to get
the summer kicked off right let's do
this hope y'all celebrate summer
everyone has somewhere in this time is
no different it's for the july z
we're set with fireworks we didn't listen
to see what though
yeah it is hold on lucy what
does it even mean to yell hold
on but not too tightly oh oh
okay to play on hold on tight
yes which ever it's a play on
that yes they're having fun with language
yes the english i think that is
a lot of fun do you think
in other languages they have fun i
doubt it
they might i don't know do you
think you're italian puns impossible
why would they ever do would play
why would they third languages are better
let's face it english is a mess
is it's it's kind of i mean
they they don't call english a romance
language for just five
i don't think they could ever yeah
but i mean it's like there's bias
in calling you know italian and spanish
romance languages don't you think well no
the term means bias ah romance language
yeah call it what it's good i
would say if i was on wheel
of fortune ah bias oh you can
only buy elser i have to go
no this further prove my point you
should do it with real funds opposite
will afford where you have to buy
a constant light as well afford to
come you show them you sell tell
the vowels to sell available this week
yeah but you do this what the
fuck man i want
no because i want you can do
chapo wheel of fortune four times and
maybe this would certainly be shit we
talked about wheel emerging from a will
of my weekend we recently talked about
it at length why because we talked
about how there should be a new
version called hangman and we just talked
about how we've all spun the wheel
or no youtube have i was price
is right was premier you but that
got us into the
wheel of fortune conversation dip shit
why don't we play wheel of my
weekend and you guessed what okay i'm
gonna guess you watch the squirrel cam
it is certainly didn't i have to
i have to i have to recharge
the camera how you gotta know who
knows what they're up to
robbie blah
what did you say you want i
can't imagine you doing anos no you
don't so specific i know trying what
if i got it right that would
be amazing you being so cagey you
made pretzels from scratch yes scott and
then you unmade pretzels from scratch that's
called because my
matter can neither be created or destroyed
so i was wrong here man yeah
i was like i made him and
unmade
ball's in your court and on the
seventh day you rested so tired what
did i do i'm gonna say i
know i saw you i saw you
post a picture with some people oh
you saw some people did post a
picture with some people yeah i posted
a picture with some people yeah you
owe restaurant or something let's see are
we beginning to lean on friday friday
i'll say fry idea
i love the chicken riaa let me
yeah what i do and we already
learned not cover friday oh yeah even
bother yeah we were like forget it
but you guys don't consider friday part
of the weekend interest oh i know
what i did i know what i
did last summer i still know what
i did last summer me too i'll
always know i saw that was the
third one today
oh you know always know what you
did like once you know you can't
undo the crowd right forget unless you
forgot that someone murdered people i'm proud
to say that on friday afternoon we
recorded um the episode one of the
new season of the neighbourhood listen it's
so i've started doing that again very
glad about that was saturday dinner with
friends wow dinner with friends at a
friend's home at a friend's home was
this group this group was an eclectic
mix of people yeah some people from
los angeles california living here full-time yeah
some people merely visiting from minneapolis minnesota
wow this sounds credible it was incredible
and
very sweet dog named gordy oh and
cook or did you get food we
ordered thai food from a place and
let me tell you every single thing
was delicious that's great shout em out
if you want to i wish i
knew the guy oh i don't know
bother memorizing the name because it was
in a different neighborhood and i knew
they wouldn't deliver oh yeah and i
was like forget it yeah
okay um i'm always what i love
i love the order in dinner with
friends but i'm always very impressed by
people who cook for friends i am
too but i feel like i because
i because i'm not a cook and
janie is i feel ah i feel
i feel bad if if like i
initiate a plan like hey let's have
those people over and eventually it's james
yes responsibility yeah and then i'm i'm
always suggesting that we could just order
food yeah we've started cool up and
i want to start a steakhouse in
our house what does that mean you'd
have like a room that's just like
ruth's chris yeah basically for like i'm
so sorry for
eight people i pictured you guys sitting
in cars but you said steak house
yes in r and then i said
in our house yes i think we
were city and carson are high side
you said you wanted to do a
stakeout oh and i thought well whatever
they wanted to drive me yes richard
dreyfuss rosie o'donnell emilio estefan says see
um no but we started ah we
we started making steaks occasionally if people
come over and so it are good
and then and then we also have
sides that ah that coop makes i
make mistakes she makes society that's great
and sound like cops to me this
sounds like a stakeout yeah yeah come
on over we'll make mistakes she makes
us
huh yeah come on over we do
whatever you normally do
you're good observed their binoculars so why
not show hey if you guys sell
your car in the driveway and watched
your guests in the backyard
but you'd you'd go to that right
and said i went to sterling over
to someone's house oh absolutely i you
know i would like to get good
at cooking i'm kind of sick of
saying i don't know how to do
this because when i use a recipe
i can make something so i'm like
yeah just look up a recipe chest
and i've gone through phases where i
like oh no i make this one
thing from this book that i cook
what i don't like is when a
recipe uses a word that they go
like everyone knows what this is if
you cook ally right you know i
like to be solely explained and i
i just got these books um buy
this cook cookbook chef yeah i guess
she's a chef and she made cookbooks
she's not cooking author but i guess
she is as well which assure that
yeah driving me crazy
just continue her instagram is called what's
gaby cooking and it's her name is
gabby i thought it was gabby but
it's gobby this is not dropping from
no scenary potter and we just cool
you made it really fun things on
it we got a couple cookbooks and
we made margarita cucumber margarita is from
the cookbook and it was really owe
you
a book that's party as some drink
so it's like well it's one for
like a whole night you yes this
this and this and you at least
thirteen years
so you're like let's make that and
we had a lot of fun we
never make anything like that i'm saying
i don't focus on anything i don't
make anything bad it wasn't like that
baby well i yeah yeah from scratch
yeah scratch yeah um what if she
whatever recipe was roast dhabi would you
eat it i've explained very clearly and
if i knew how to
get the dobie because i think the
yes bluer than with socks right i
think that is what i do but
i love size is the hardest thing
for me about cooking and i love
it if you know you guys have
any suggestions on this i'm talking more
to youtube than for the listener um
because they you can hear that yeah
can't hear what they're gonna say that
makes it by and you won't when
i
messages when i look in a recipe
yeah the thing that overwhelms me is
idea that if i'm gonna do this
a lot i kind of get all
this shit every fucking time yeah well
you've got to stock your share like
the herbs and whatnot yeah you kind
of have those robots spices have at
least seven libs but like if it's
like yeah fireworks show
my hat all that stuff but i'm
saying i'm talking about like like if
it's something that has like fifteen things
like go in it and you're like
oh my god i gotta go to
the store gotta find all these little
things as a nice shade well this
is why this is why if you're
night shade what my mother would do
a little my mother would shop once
a week and plan out the meals
for all seven okay
santa look at me like that i
gotta be like and then yeah i
knew you consolidate darth vader cake you
also do leftovers for some of it
make a darth vader cake out of
a bell yeah um but you know
like you just kind of plan out
the week like okay this is these
are the things i'm gonna make i
mean i would have to write it
down oh come out well because i
lose my little get my plans
over and over again like i like
i have the same idea five times
if i don't write down yeah that's
what malcolm gladwell said that our genius
has the same idea five times unless
they write it down no that's the
secret to success oh you have the
same idea of five times but then
write it down never read it never
ideal but five times having it yeah
one time too
two times three times four times five
yeah yeah yeah well what happens i'm
like i'd love to cook and then
it's five o'clock and i'm starving and
i'm like i'll just yeah whenever the
fuck i have yeah yeah hey man
back to the weekend yeah yeah last
night early evening what happened a friend's
birthday drinks yeah well you
i would do the second thing yeah
whoa yeah haha i had this burger
that was so fucking good where was
it this place called verdugo oh yeah
i don't think i've a sandwich from
the hamburg region yeah wow yeah an
important sandwich wow from germany it was
delicious
it was short it was it was
my sloppy burger with so so good
yeah so so good so so good
i had in and out yes my
mouth watering thinking about oh wow i
have to confess i hadn't now on
thursday yeah i had a three by
three protein style wow hey let me
tell you about friday what we did
what the fuck is through by three
that's three
patties three cheese ooh yes jack double
double yeah three and there's a four
by four that's a lot for us
to not why i'm not mad that
you ate it but i'm saying it
seems like your mouth can open that
wide try me
you know you're going to unhinge his
jaw oh like he eats piglets this
thing is like a really thick thing
i mean you know it's it's it's
very i don't want that huge thing
it's like if you don't want to
do two double doubles and have all
that bread i see him if you
do a prologue that way
do double doubles so you know that
bread so friday ah reality recap yeah
friday friday gotta come on friday yeah
so our friend ah sang who's a
chef ah he'll the chef also saying
that i didn't have to follow your
sentence yeah my friend my friend
and saying thank you and he is
a chef thank you and he ah
appeared a magician too yes and then
he
operated um no he was on a
television show hosted by natasha lucero called
rat in the kitchen and he was
on an episode earlier in the season
where he and it's spoilers for the
show if you're catching up to it
but ah the show is basically there
are six i
believe chefs all trying to create a
bunch of dishes six and one is
a rat trying to spoil all the
dishes when they go around and put
something in the meal they can do
it however they want retro it's so
rad as long as now robin makes
terminator company so sad nobody they put
something in then you're like yeah because
taste bad now
oh yes so basically basically there's fifty
thousand dollars ah there's fifty thousand dollars
in and then the chef ludo is
is judging it and is it a
new land you six every episode new
six every episode and then chef ludo
tasted and i think thinking about somebody
saying that every single time
in this case like shit said oh
it's not even planned it's just what
everybody says yes yeah just taste bad
no
so they assign ah an amount of
money to each dish like five thousand
dollars and then or two dollars and
then he tastes it all day he
gives it a pass or he gives
it a thumbs down and if he
if it gets a thumbs down ask
themselves just the rat has the right
gets that money right and it's a
real rat it's an actual red yeah
it's ratatouille oh look every time now
knows well his voice
saying a real rat yeah huh but
anyway so he was he was on
the show earlier in the season and
he was the rat and he was
ooh and he won like i think
it was twenty five thousand dollars like
he got the money and then no
one gets to his him so these
are professional chefs know i mean some
of them are professionals some of them
are amateurs you can tell
um so anyway he won earlier in
the season and so then this was
the season finale and they had a
bunch of the rats back and made
one of them back it was the
rat pack back uh-huh and so he
came over and he made wrap some
around no he made us all rats
why he did
it turns us all into a magician
yeah tension all the way yeah
yes and now i am a rat
as you see look at me guys
you haven't looked at me like oh
my god you are a rat's yeah
when your metallica shirt changed
funds it was what it said swords
words funds you were where you get
it anyway so he made he made
ah some of his loud food he's
ah specializes in lao food yeah for
us all with a bunch of friends
and we watched his episode oh how
fun and ah can
convinced he was going to be the
rat again and i won't spend he
wouldn't say a word he would not
he was signed an nva and would
not tell us anything until he put
gross stuff and all the food you
are going to eat so that he'd
be like yeah and see see how
i did that would have been amazing
know it is interesting what they would
do like his his thing was he
would he would just like casually go
by everyone's ovens and turn it up
as
high as they would go as he
was like passing by that's a good
one
and what i would like blaze up
or i'm just going to just blaze
up in overcook everything oh ma and
some fun that's for sure like some
of the rats would just like walk
by with seasoning in their hands and
just like like to drop and oversaw
everything crop just like that yeah crop
dusted but you can't do it to
everybody right because then obviously if you're
the only one who has good
good dish and it's like hey i
think he's the well weirdly enough already
saying wow you're steven do it to
his own dish did it to everyone
else's dish sorry because say okay and
that guy that threw everyone off his
scent because they were like oh he's
doing good so he's not the rad
he's like he's making good dishes i
don't see
see how that makes any sense yeah
because the rat if they're working on
their own dishes and spoiling it that's
what everyone was thinking of like oh
the rat it was sabotage their own
dish but nobody else's yeah but it
doesn't make any sense to me now
i know it doesn't make any sense
to me either it's i just feel
like you'd have to leave one tiny
branch oh yeah oh yeah yes
one other person anyway fighting or just
do a little salt in one of
them doesn't really change it well they
do they actually they do rotate on
most of the dishes were like everyone
gets a chance at working on each
dish so oh so it could be
many people because yes exactly so i
i've not had enough sleep to grasp
how the show works you don't need
to
to bed jordan and i will do
the shows watch it i know y'all
want just watched all of it today
why oh mercy let us know if
you get it now you know what's
back is an old fave of ours
borgen the danish tv series you're everything
ours as well and i was like
i know i don't know what this
now and
his what in my lovely wife oh
you have a favorite together yeah it's
it's a danish tv show about the
danish government is to drama and it's
very good boy born again there you
go i were to wound it scott
what paul can't believe you're sabotaging my
enjoyment of the shiloh rats you know
three might get anymore
right in the three-day yeah i've been
sabotaging this whole show ever since the
beginning and it all got rat and
the freedom those brushy doing i think
great oh good he was thriving i
hope so oh i know is that
he made his you know money on
the gofundme and kickstarter yes for his
new album he's he's just killing go
fund me is
a tough name because it's like it
starts with go fuck go fund yourself
yeah you know go fuck like me
could be anything yeah and then suddenly
it's like could be any evenings me
yeah well one of the other ah
but what are the other things it
could be go far other for go
far further
go further than you've ever gone before
go finally go fun go go fun
time go fun time for gopher gopher
on the love boat go from the
vote go over on the love boat
d d and um scott about yeah
are we
can you want to see your dao
oh no i saw the weirdest person
named al that i know yeah preferring
it's part of his name yeah he's
not a regular owl no no no
no no no no no where was
the show this is at the wiltern
which is a beautiful theater a beautiful
theater shooter ah and ah perform
and there once with mister show thing
were you this right did you do
that as well the mister show kids
in the hall crossover yeah yeah i
sang a song or something at the
end of the clash of the titans
really question the times yes laughter laughter
cures cancer yes the name of song
and it did it did thank god
everybody just in time go um but
yeah so ah went with andy day
wally and his daughter um and cool
op oh cool up was there yes
colaba says cool up and i um
and ah it was a great show
al this was his show where he's
doing all like deep cuts no parodies
pretty good
yeah lol rarities way wait i don't
know about this yes so he is
a lot of his own it's his
own original ridge yeah seated everyone's sitting
down and he's doing his own original
season i'm doing postcards says claw the
seated meaning to performers on stage oh
the audience the audience
the audience the audience stand the audience
also know they take turns anytime i
would said we would sit and vice
versa that's fun i you know what
my favorite concert is a criss cross
applesauce where everyone is sitting on the
ground yeah wow wow hey what does
the game and did you play this
yeah we're one person yes thank you
do you really want your watch
know where one person one person to
hide and then if you found that
auctions sardine oh i don't know this
if you found the right thing where
you hide with them oh and then
everyone just joins and oh yes see
reverse hide and seek because yeah one
person hides everyone else sits hide and
hide and then you hide in hide
and hide side yeah it's
a very cute and cozy game is
cute i mean everyone's just in the
shower you know at the end yeah
everyone thinks the shower outside yeah we
played outside nude sardines
gotta your t-shirt oh my god one
new shirt new color new coed sorry
yeah this was insane one time in
fifth grade i was with two friends
and this one was a new girl
who'd moved to town and we were
was very her bullying her know we're
here in her yard and we were
playing blurry the new girl off
f or something but i don't even
know if that was blind man's bluff
and even if we were playing around
this book is where somebody has to
close their eyes and things like marco
polo mccoy yeah exact yes because that
is what we were playing and she
were playing them and she ran headfirst
into a big tree o or nose
it was broken and he crazy and
sane and then we went home didn't
die no i mean like her family
was like we we have to take
care of his thigh you know buy
and then you never found out what
happened after that well i'm shy did
i mean we we saw her at
school okay but she wasn't like this
the last you saw of her no
but i mean it was
so i was horrified i remember very
if you were like and then we
never saw her again it was interesting
it was just so just never came
back to school i wonder whatever happened
to that awful somebody told me ah
so you had a girlfriend she had
a friend ne
last february she said um that they
oh god who wasn't somebody that i
know
i think my friend julie that they
threw up in school and then moved
after that oh and then everyone assumed
it was because they because they think
everyone assumed was yeah they were embarrassing
i do know my friend told me
that when he was in high school
now this is rock-solid you notice your
medical i know he told us
that there was a there was a
girl who was wearing an all white
outfit oh yeah and she's she was
like the popular girl in school and
she was wearing all white and then
she was making out with a guy
in a pickup truck and they were
drunk and then she started getting sick
and she lean
turned out the the door and puked
and ashy puke she diarrhea all over
the moses with a white outfit and
then she had to move away yeah
absolutely you went out to move away
i hope i i hope she's changed
her identity they end it was laura
lapidus yeah hey okay hey
guy hey tiffany brown
hence the name change um i am
wondering if you were ever passed in
schools we had a big panting know
that they didn't they didn't say fish
huh
they hadn't invented that yeah okay gym
class panting everyone's in the elastic shorts
kevin's nodding um really horrific stuff kevin
kevin pant you pants pete doesn't hurt
a woman to pants a woman doesn't
hurt a woman dependable pretty embarrassing you
know like going to war be danced
yeah one time this girl was pants
and her um
labia fell off so wow pat oh
wow this is why you don't do
it to learn the kids this is
for the kids don't pants a woman
don't pay your command there could be
a pad up there don't pull anyone's
pants down it's not yours to do
without panting was pulling them up um
no you're pulling would be like playing
basketball in the gym
when someone just run up and like
that's actually like sexual assaults yeah it's
not good fucked up yeah you're saying
it was happening so much was like
an epidemic it was like i remember
just like you have to like hold
onto your pants or does doing it
as an adult that would make me
laugh
you imagine
people running around the basketball court
gripping their own pants
unable to wow his passable thursday knocking
with their chest when it comes to
that
we should do that to each other
no we shouldn't
leave everyone's pants alone we should leave
britney alone too yeah and then they
eventually did yeah it's working out great
yeah i think so he will gets
the grease i'm glad she's doing better
i am tuesday okay well she got
married and she got to have a
special day your free brittany day
yeah yeah um i mean what do
you know what do you know
we don't
someone sent me something with invisible link
and look forward to reading the memoir
she's working on okay yeah great do
you think it will cover when she
was skinny as a neato
why are we talking about this again
now it's just the third time now
i i've retained it's all oh good
that's why we're doing like ah ah
taking it five times and then you'll
get skinny isn't happening given the reality
recap recommendation of lavalas is part of
love
spectrum you less they had an australia
season was fantastic the us version also
fantastic really good show people love them
net fee people love it yes i
love it i've just watched watching it's
really great just this really sweet show
and the parents are really supportive and
wonderful people that's what i understand is
that it's actually very it's very serious
washing
there's really exploited oh yeah no but
i guess i just don't care that's
fine i'm not even like other shows
to begin laughing know if they made
a reality show about yourself would you
watch my god every episode are you
kidding me or am i good what
am i doing this lunch you know
we want we janie and i famously
watched one reality show
it's all church on sunday southern china
southern charm which is an absolutely terrible
show it's boring he that's the thing
it's like you have you've just signed
up for the wrong one
you don't care ah but here's the
feeling now you're invested in the dome
show like swedish chef you like the
swedish swedish dumb shit
that's a reality show guy though it's
only into the swedish chef she's like
look look i've i have my thing
i'm fine i don't need anything else
i watched the swedish chef even a
person who'd like i wish he would
do more to chef memorabilia up in
their house yeah it makes me laugh
wait what is the shows eating my
guy borgen borgen and what's it about
oh it's about the danish government to
drama set in the ballast wondering if
it's like what would you compare it
to like is it like broad church
or is like west wing ah church
and parachurch it's like westwind but it's
not ernest you know what i mean
it's like it's more actual drama it's
like ernest goes west wing exactly
ah they say hey vern a la
crazy in there oh you would be
why did he ever do earnest as
the president no that was a really
missed opportunity just gonna star white house
yeah sure i mean who knows what
he would have done if he hadn't
passed away i know he probably would
turned all the water in the soda
fountains just to what
oh my god and all the driver
and the drinking her dog
tricky okay look we have to take
a break when we come back i
have an update on something we've talked
about we'll have had a cat scan
me i've talked about on the show
or a different show oh my god
what a t
and we're back high and guys did
i tell you about the the dvd
of date night that my parents displayed
in their kitchen for years you told
me about the walrus in me man
you said that you're as close as
can be mad right haha oh i
caught you up on that yeah okay
did you another clue russell ah no
melee i was just talking about the
date night maybe the date i talking
about this it must have been another
show anyways i'm gonna update you on
it sure recycle the story it's ok
so recycle it i've never told it
before because it happened last night you
said she's a capita
or another show well the first part
okay so the first part
the first part is the rest of
your life leading up to that moment
then you've already talked about it on
here the first part is that when
i would go visit my parents at
their previous house they had ah qualities
cabinets in the kitchen and allows like
everybody's house make your sky and a
lot
of them were open and used to
display things okay so like they had
no doors yes they had no doors
just the shahada mansion they were shown
haha yes okay so
and are you an alien that has
replaced our fritz remade
they were cabinets that were open to
display things that shelves know or they
actually cabinets when i took the doors
oh yes that would happen yes that's
not are they aliens what happens next
well for years i would go visit
them and there would be very nice
view
a dvd of the movie date night
starring tina fey and steve carell and
opened wrapped on a stand
aha like they're like this is a
really important for yes so we will
not watch or like this one's going
up we're gonna watch this one tonight
and they never do because you're remembering
our copy of dd yeah yeah and
it works is a beautiful your kid
up their friends' tina fey and steve
around and once or twice i believe
or a picture of them this is
all we could find once or twice
i think i said have you seen
this movie
they're like yeah we saw in the
theaters and that's as far as i
know they just like it that's as
far as you would go because i'd
be asking that a lot more questions
yeah well i didn't want to intrude
sure well so and i believe i'd
talked about this probably on another show
scott hasn't seen where we date night
may have come up and i was
like i have no idea why they
used to but and and it's doesn't
seem to be an important movie to
them you're
thinking about this story is that date
night would have come up in conversation
yeah like i let anything goes hey
steve carell have talked about that since
i think you would surprise them if
you showed them the dvd
so for for the past ten years
i don't know when date night came
out but i've wondered about this right
so last night i think sleep yeah
i just like cool it's for him
cool appliques over your wig are you
thinking about data
it's just so funny how people approach
their parents different because i was like
why are you displaying this this is
so weird i may have said that
in there they go i don't know
but um but so last night i
see that bird uf he might have
said last night i see them okay
and they have ah and my mom
has a box for me and she
goes do you want a bottle of
wine and does she say it like
that yeah
why because anytime you see your she's
getting rid of her things and being
like do you want this i say
no to half of it but she's
so beleaguered about yes yes okay well
life is is is beleaguering man that's
true that's oh so she's like do
you want about all why i say
yeah sure why and she says i
do
ain't no my sister and her husband
gave us this
because they said have you seen the
movie date-night
and we said yeah in the theaters
and they said well we got you
this wine based on the movie date
night y and we've never understood it
and then i realized that this box
of the bottle of wine was next
to the dvd of data i gave
them the gift with the dvd maybe
with the dvd or or my parents
bought the dvd to be like nice
to them of like look we displayed
your bottle next to the dvd of
date-night like old person thing yeah and
they never understood what this bot
all of wine has to do with
data i've ever seen date night so
i don't know what wine has to
do a date night wait are you
goodness here now i feel like i
have to see date-night to understand i've
seen my era where my mom yes
i don't know but they don't even
know you have to see it now
because i need to know i need
to know and i don't want anyone
to send me messages of oh it
refer
we're in dayton if you do send
them in invisible ink ah yeah you
need to do you need to have
a date night with cool off where
you drink that wine and watch date
night randy finally figure out what the
fuck is going yeah so i don't
know but i'm gonna say you can't
open the wine until you figure out
what it has to do an excellent
way to celebrate we pop it up
once and yeah i'm wondering when the
one that's done
because if the is pretty old and
they have a dvd and it might
be really valuable wine probably sold it
could be worth a lot from the
movie um what have you tried to
sell it like date night wine this
has to do with the movie date-night
yeah i rarely tell there's one other
flu there's one other clue she mentioned
the word genealogy which i don't know
what it had and she didn't even
know she's like
like it has something to do with
genealogy or something i don't know what
i find but yeah writers of date-night
are listening to this going what we
did what
who but yeah see this is you
never know when you create something like
date night you never know who it's
gonna touch and and the tendrils that
are going to you know and that's
so beautiful yeah create a movie old
people make it weird around it so
be careful so the date night mystery
continues but is close to being solved
at lee
right now i know or i have
an idea of why they were displaying
date night because i think they wanted
to be good doesn't do it for
nine your sister if her sister ever
visited did she ever doubtful does she
live in another state or so yes
well they did at the time yeah
i didn't really see mike's mom doing
something like that to be nice to
the person like it's like out
out and then they come over she
puts it out yeah come over some
but i mean a lot of what
my mom so they get the wine
i'm like wow should probably display this
and really like make it nice to
really nice edc yeah and put that
on the stand yeah yeah yeah yeah
i actually i actually feel like i
really get this i know it may
knowing me knowing my mom's yeah there
is
this more little sense how do i
put this it's like a sorta like
a very it's very thoughtful gesture it's
very win so maybe you were thoughtful
when someone gives you something she feels
were when someone gives her something she
feels a responsibility to enjoy it to
the extent that she's making a little
shrine making trends but also she has
kept
stuff for now fifty sixty years that
she is now offloading to me oh
of like oh you're your great grandmother
gave me this when i was just
got married when i was eighteen and
it's a brand of energy on the
bob newhart show i've never used it
do you want it and i
you just have to say yeah most
of the time now i say donate
nowadays i say i absolutely do and
then i throw it away the minute
i get whatever just in the kitchen
trash and you're like yeah absolutely i
just really see how well one thing
i did was gonna keep this here
one thing i did throw in the
trash last night funny you should say
that is we we all played a
game
and it was so it was i
forget what it was called but it
was it was where you ah ask
a question and everyone writes down their
answers and tasks how you get to
know each other oh yeah anyway so
so we all play it and it's
fun or whatever and then and by
the way she's had me get it
from the closet where it's underneath and
she's like last time i tried to
get
something from the closet everything fell on
my head so you get it and
i'm like ok so it's underneath a
ton of stuff right and so we
play the game
ah we have fun and i go
that's a fun game did you just
get it she's like no ah the
her family friends got it for her
like twenty five years ago and that's
the last time they played it or
something she's like it was so fun
and i always wanted to play it
again and by the way we didn't
want to burn it out so we
waited for you
by the way there are score pads
she has done what she does with
all games she doesn't want to run
out of the score pads so she
xeroxed off all of the score pads
made extra was oh my god they're
they're all just sitting there new in
this had never occurred to me to
do oh yeah wow so oh so
i'm like so i'll never use them
up it's like
yeah how often gonna play this game
well this is what this is my
thing i don't think this is a
recurring game that we're gonna play ever
again we have our games as a
family that we play a lot and
i didn't think this was going to
be one of them so i'm like
ok well i'll put it back so
i you know do the whole you
know taking every all the games out
everything down during some of the stuff
on your head but no nothing
i'll buy my head but and i
put it back underneath the thing could
you tell it that some stuff going
alright so did you feel like you
had everything back where it was yes
okay because i knew it wasn't gonna
be in the current rotation and i
didn't want it to be sitting up
and it's like a fuckin jenga in
there yes yes yeah decide it back
so i put it exactly where it
was and it was a big ordeal
but i finally got it done
and then i then i go back
to where everyone played and there is
one card from the game bought there
like an essential non of paper it's
just one of the cards with questions
on it and by the way there
are five thousand three hundred cards in
this thing and we used so not
five thousand we are we use third
a lot i mean that was a
crazy guess five thousand yeah you're right
but there say there are three hundred
cards yeah we use thirty of them
and they have four questions and you
only use one question per let's throw
it out well this is what i
did sensibly i see this and i
go oh and then my mom goes
oh no you got to put it
back
in the thing i go mom i'm
just gonna throw it away realizing no
one in this family is ever going
to play this game again right yeah
and so if if this is the
timeline they're all yes this is the
last time they're like oh i'm just
going to throw it away and she's
like no oh okay and then they're
one of the one of the questions
when we're playing the game was written
poorly that no one understood
i didn't and i said oh it's
that question anyway it doesn't matter lie
yeah but to make her feel better
i find out later she has dug
through the trash it's the guard boats
and was going to put it back
herself but then it had a lot
of like food on it and so
she
so she
i ended up throwing it away and
feeling okay about it oh just vote
on it yeah yes well there you
go you just gotta put food on
more stuff and then she can get
rid of it that is heavy it's
heavy meme yeah i mean i love
the task of getting rid of stuff
like i feel like she needs someone
she's like an organizer to go
over there and be like let's let
twelve games down to the sixty law
like the celebrity organizers yeah just you
know things on hanging that has already
happened that no no no i'm talking
somebody who's gonna dig through that i
did i've served that purpose myself huh
when we moved her back into california
and so she's she's in prague
since i'm doing that and feels better
about it and there are all these
like things that like old records that
we had when i was a kid
that she hadn't she'd carried around from
house to house and hadn't listened to
and and i was like mom i'm
just going to throw these away and
she's like but i loved them when
you were kids and i go i
so did i but you haven't even
looked at them
well yeah tell me about this just
like like nursery rhymes shit yeah yeah
yeah so i mean if yeah yeah
that's tough because i feel like i
feel very nostalgic for things that i
like to keep a lot of stuff
i keep like every mostly my stuff
is more like sentimental like that is
sometimes yes i know but i'll keep
like cards and
not but i've started to be better
about that but i have a lot
of them from when i was growing
up and i have like all the
letters my friends and i ever wrote
to each other and like also like
that yeah and then i have all
my now i have all the best
of my toys which i might have
mentioned that i like sent them all
back from my mom's tucked into a
huge undertaking yeah there's a lot it
was a lot of stuff and i
was like she has saved it for
so long it's all
tough that i love and it's all
in great condition and i'm excited to
like you know have it for my
family but it's just it's interesting cause
it's also that thing of like well
we'll holly wanna play with this old
thing or we'll shoot more yeah but
we'll see but i mean i it's
it's a lot i mean like with
the records i could imagine myself taking
those but i also like what i
have i could imagine
than than myself taking those in and
looking glancing at them every once in
a while but i'll tell you once
we just once i said we're just
going to donate these and then they
went away neither of us have thought
about them and yeah i'm talking about
them right now and that you know
what i mean and it was like
such a weight off of everyone's yeah
i love to donate something that's just
been a wait
yeah and you're like get this out
of here yeah now i'm have at
a crossroads right now because i'm trying
i'm always trying to get rid of
stuff um and i have a bunch
of baseball caps that i dug out
of the closet because they're just taking
up so much space and i'm like
like all of i like all of
these right even though i haven't worn
yeah but i think that's okay it's
really hard but it's just it's just
taking up space and it's like then
you have to go into okay top
of each other this month i'm wearing
monkeys will steal them scott you gotta
go this month i'm wearing every slow
up i'm sorry you got
put them on rotation yeah well right
here's what's happening right now is since
it's baseball season yeah i have my
i have many ah phillies caps so
i wear those daily daily then yeah
be around the house and shit outside
of the house
if i have to go out there
yes sure yeah um but i keep
them in i keep them all in
the house i don't know if you
understand what i'm saying they they're inside
your house unless you go outside yes
if they go outside it's because i'm
wearing one yeah you're not you're not
let me start to beginning you're not
putting them outside and enforcing outside i
don't have i don't have house hats
outside and
it's inside right guys is that what
you thought well sorry you're wearing on
if you're wearing a house if you're
wearing a house oh okay well that
says yes let's start over yes so
i have my house that's sure ah
but then when the phillies ah should
they by some weird chance get knocked
out of the running i get for
the postseason
then i switch over to my dad
drops right but what are these herbal
amount of them that you're talking about
that you are fond of are they
other teams are just phillies they're not
sports related oh i see some of
them are souvenir things some of them
are just cool things that happen along
ram
well okay so there's two claws yeah
one can only tell the truth um
one is a little shallow closet where
we keep like our raincoats should we
ever need them in the shallow hello
yeah in the shallow closet and then
there's a shelf overhead where i keep
the the baseball caps right
yeah right but now it's too many
baseball yeah and so i put all
of this the phillies ones up there
then i got all these other ones
just like in the closet on top
of the shoe rack and stuff like
that that's tough it's sloppy and messy
and it makes me feel what have
you i don't know if this is
a thing but i imagine it is
like
a sort of plea over admission to
or inside the closet being over the
door hanging thing that's like to basically
science it's honestly like the hats hanging
off of little peg i have seen
things like that there are mirrors inside
the closet door which makes it a
little bit difficult because it's like do
you want to cover up a mirror
your hats yeah and and frankly i
don't yeah i don't think you don't
know that kind of guy the other
option is you get like a sort
of teddy bear and put an chair
and then stack all the hats on
top of it yeah so the reason
i was feeling this i like yeah
i like this and it's almost it's
as high as a stripper pole
and i that is to say like
hi yes stripper plants
high is a thing that was all
the way up to the ceiling guys
yeah alright we have today arabic
and we're back and we're back and
it's time for one threesome know this
richer one three don't go to one
freedom plaza and that's where you'll find
the creature museum by the way we
haven't talked about this this is early
morning threesome for all of us because
we've ever recorded right yeah and so
that's why we're
all our synapses are not firing correctly
we started i've been up for five
hours but surely two yeah five thirty
yeah i woke up at five for
no reason yeah two hours before my
alarm and yet so that doesn't help
because you just feel tired and it's
like one dog it's like i got
swim again i mean yeah you know
this young very titled record later i'd
say i just get tired
tired okay ooh do you know this
thing where you wake up earlier than
you intended to wake up and you're
lying there in bed try to go
actually you don't go back to sleep
you think oh well i'm awake i'm
going to start my day yeah then
about a half hour into that you're
like oh yes take yeah yeah i've
had a cup of coffee and now
everything's ruined yeah
that's where i am right now and
that sounds good so well in any
case we're going to do a three
ter and this is an old favorite
this is switched in pitch it switch
in pitch it switching and pitches switching
the budget and dating back to our
earliest episodes we got wow these were
those early days oh god everything's so
different old faithful
i call this one now this is
where ah is i believe i believe
it's one person pitches to two people
yeah and ah ah the one person
who's pitching we give that person the
title of an existing television show or
movie yes and they have to switch
every letter into the opposite letter no
this is not letter a word every
word into the opposite word every other
the directly opposite thirteen away on a
sliding scale
yeah every every word is the like
an opposite word and then they have
to pitch that show and then at
the end of it they have to
sing the theme song to shit correct
as well yeah and that's great so
and that's a great thing paul do
you want to be the first person
to pitch sure okay
i'm going to look up classic tv
shows and find a good one great
and ah i have found nothing yet
okay
true blood true blood okay oh okay
so anyway yeah okay i know and
that's why it's not gonna work out
i look and i'm telling you i
need this to work it's not going
to so you have to sell it
now okay well where am i supposed
to sell this list i don't know
figure it out should i not have
come in oh i'm sorry you know
you shouldn't sign who let you in
xxl uni you should come on in
you guys start having
archdale and right yes sprouse
not today you don't let the gas
know that things aren't great we were
having a little bit sorry yeah i'm
selling something well yeah better be you're
selling something to sprouse here no to
anyone i bought something the monies back
yeah oh i see what are you
guys together no no no okay no
we're just this we were two people
who met
at when i bought something of hers
and then i hired him to work
at this company yeah ok and i
rose above her and now in president
of the grey okay and then i
rose above him and i'm the actual
ceo wow but then i rose above
that buying a i became the head
of another company and i bought out
this company was crazy ears
i rose above that but both companies
and then i made it to nobody
can buy anything yeah it was in
all the contracts and you guys still
personally hear pitches yes yeah we like
to control you know wanna hear what's
going on what we wanna make sure
we get the true controllers foam yeah
exactly yeah you guys are cool but
really hands-on yeah i'm saying
hands-on i want to put my hands
on yeah oh yeah we only hear
one pitch a year yeah oh this
is an honor i have no idea
we don't know the last pitch we
heard was three hundred and sixty four
days ago ok so sometimes it's too
yeah okay so what am i supposed
to do want to come back tomorrow
would you prefer that yes
okay i'll see you tomorrow okay
hey time to go do that pitch
how you didn't get to do it
yet anyway so i know they told
me to come back the next day
what anyway i i sold it i
finally sold think guy now how much
money did you get i got three
dollars are you fucking kidding me and
it was a three dollar bill as
well and it was counterfeit eye candy
oh he's bow he's back hi dylan
sprouse hi it's okay though can we
hear your pitch please yes i am
excited you know what project i'm realising
that the last pitch we heard was
at nine thirty am zeno more and
it is nine
twenty eight i'm going to go to
the starbucks and then turn right back
around it's only two minutes though i
know i know the starbucks in the
building oh okay the one with the
one in the corner yeah one of
the spotlight okay we're so rich we
bought a starbucks and have a corner
over me yeah exactly no i'm telling
him i know yeah i'm not here
thing so anything i tell him you're
gonna say you don't have to tell
me yes alright hey you know that
starbucks because two minutes have elapsed anna
back hey guys yet i'm i didn't
get anything i didn't bring any money
with me oh because i figured i
would get it at the end of
this pitch oh smart thinkers yeah so
you're putting yourself into the position where
you have to sell this pitch oh
yeah because i've emptied my bank account
i just threw the money away you're
like jim carrey writing yourself a check
for a million dollars yeah that my
asking cash yes but maybe you can
i ask and cash thing no great
is it a tv show it is
a tv show huh now yeah we
all know the world of the supernatural
we all know this yeah absolutely okay
and we all know the world of
frank and stein oh yeah so er
doctor earth in both k
aces yes this takes place on earth
great love it i'm ready to buy
ah whole don't not don't jump to
anything yeah don't don't jump to i'm
tired of doing non earth shows i
want to design that on her so
many shows and mars i think you
guys are gonna be thrilled to have
your first show set on earth okay
frankenstein the ancient monster he's ancient wow
by today's standards around here eighteen hundred
yeah pretty old yeah there's not like
prehistoric that's pretty much why didn't say
for sure thank strauss my own tomato
side here what
wow so you're about to buy the
show don't disagree with me in front
of the tv-show we're gonna be working
a lot with tomato i'll come back
tomorrow no yeah i think you should
okay
mental wake up later hey it's my
birthday and you're gonna leave again and
do this pitch i'm sorry today's i
gotta get away hey spouse and i
decided to come to you when you're
at your hood meeting your wife wait
oh hey pretty sexy wife over here
oh thanks spouse i figured
gonna like her she sounds a lot
like you really yeah oh my god
yeah our voices but it's okay when
people say the same you know it's
wise alright why would it not be
ok um oh my you sleep in
the nude yeah i do in the
buff to be rude in my birthday
suit it's actually my name my birthday
yeah i sleep in her birthday suit
oh happy birthday oh no actually yourself
no i'm saying sir we actually brought
her oh i'm sorry i thought you
were saying take your sunglasses brought her
you just sound so similar you put
the cake okay here you go we
brought this cake for you sprouse ooh
it's later ve la
either his wife what's his wife's name
krauss wait whose birthday is it how's
this it's crows yeah lindsay crops that's
my wife oh yes your crowds yeah
from house of game yo car lindsay
no i call it krauss steven i
was big fan of the tv show
benson tell me about david mamet was
like being married to him down what
i like yeah tell me about did
you know his issue he
and this year our wedding and he
made us put pauses in certainly we
had to do them exactly love and
respect that so are you ready to
pitch yes i am i was i
woke up ready yeah i woke up
like this ready to pitch you definitely
did so you remember how it's talking
about frankenstein stoner cut glass
i don't know if that's true but
it would i have some glass right
here you rub it up against your
boner yeah i guess the answer is
no
well anyway so you know frankenstein isn't
a real guide to shower because i
saw on that glass cross and yeah
please stop embarrassing week for admission we
play the reverse i see a birthday
yeah let's play sardines this place aids
you first go in the shower only
find you you pitch
watch the show
thank god we tricked him into taking
a shower he's pretty oh well if
he's just rubbing shot oh give away
they'll know exactly where
i'll go find it and also just
turn it off okay alright gotcha i'll
get in here with you hey here
i am oh right
hey hey lindsay oh and here i
go by kraus was very great company
what what fuckers do my husband were
just doing a pitch oh just doing
about it julia sardines pit hey just
tell us the name of the show
we get out of your hair know
i needed to just the name
please tell us the name no please
please i'm for big highwood practicing this
pitch for day one name comes at
the end yes okay fine just tell
us tell us frankenstein is not real
right he's made up of a bunch
of corpses and shit so he's not
a
real guy right and so
his mouth gets really try okay and
he goes on all the time my
mouth is watering hearing the whole world
over in search of an artificial spit
and this show's called false saliva paul
sliwa whoa
all shows about frankenstein trying to find
artificial spit i think we should buy
this and he he held you back
c o soul i don't know why
i'm adding more because you're gonna give
me extra money oh extra money okay
yeah we do we might tip you
incredible hulk or littlest hobo style he
helps people out in the town that
he goes to as he searched
paying for this spit wow here's three
dollars
here's five thank you c crowds i
told you so nathaniel million dollar bill
dollars today yeah oh great i barely
even got out of bed yeah it's
not still not good i mean even
showered yet i already made eight dollars
alright you know we want to buy
but it's dependent on one thing
the theme song oh yeah yeah yeah
they go are you ready yeah yeah
because i composed it yep using it
as well oh okay this is a
treat
ooh and you gotta admit any i
got i do it now you need
fall saliva how ya gonna do come
and the span id full for lima
full full full full balsa live
wow i don't know that we can
afford the song rights no yeah oh
i'm so sorry now that you've heard
it you have to pay for it
oh them you didn't read the quilted
how much of your time oh how
much much is that why i'm afraid
that's going to set you back the
cost of the show so
so you're looking at eight dollars more
i'm out a three dollar bills and
fives i only have eights oh i
have a five though you have eight
yeah oh just give me a nathan
alright a pleasure doing business with you
goodbye forever goodbye forever
you guys are still here yeah go
figure how to get this weird huh
yeah how did you get out of
here there's no windows and no doors
yeah that's how we like it okay
it's not how we like you to
toe he likes it and my birthday's
done but i guess i still yeah
i'm here and i have my i
want to say you won't
i want to divorce ko-fi why because
you said you hate me and you
can't wait to get away from me
oh shit that's right you have to
say something to me five times before
it really sinks in i want to
force i want a divorce i want
a divorce i want a divorce i
want a divorce and technically should a
sunken sooner etc reset at one house
i've spent twenty four hours here and
i'm in love with
you okay this is perfect because this
means that i have a good way
out let me be your exit hatch
ok cool sprouse yeah are you able
to bear children let me take your
pants down
bad okay good
okay okay because i want a lot
of time good call good read to
the police station now i'm yeah i'm
sorry yes and i'm going to have
everyone here arrested for oh you're just
jealous disgusting yeah i'm jealous yeah you're
joe is because we're no longer together
and crowded i love each other ever
been together and you can have crows
and she's got the bloodiest vagina
you've ever ac yeah
jesus krauss
yeah ok guys and that's how you
play and that's how you played richard
j you play guys directions so if
you play it do exactly what we
did just exactly and that's how you
play and that's how you do it
hey guess what we're three adam ah
usa on twitter and instagram three of
usa gmail dot com
if you'd like to send us a
three-tier or some um music you've composed
or some shit yeah fuck you wanna
do i'm making a theme we making
three if you have any dreams for
us we have so many departments now
mean yeah jingles yeah so it makes
it make some theme songs make some
themes um and of course our phone
umber ah haha law in pu
ibew and if you want to hear
the archives and ad-free episodes go to
stitcher premium or cb world dot com
we love you bye yes bye
uh